so one of the things that's at issue in
the alex jones defamation trial award
phase
is alex jones claim of bankruptcy now
alex jones is not bankrupt however alex
jones has filed for bankruptcy and he
has even admitted that part of it is in
order to shield or protect certain
assets from the potential settlement
that is coming
the potential award that is coming for
the defamatory statements that alex
jones made
one of the things alex jones tried to do
during his testimony is to claim i am
bankrupt and the judge actually directed
him to stop saying that that he is not
bankrupt that he may have filed for
bankruptcy but that he is not bankrupt
and he can't continue to say that
yesterday judge maya guerra gamble uh
actually talked to alex jones about what
sort of a settlement do you believe
would be fair
and alex jones trying to beg for mercy
saying even two million dollars would
sink info wars now that's sort of hard
to believe given that it's on record
that infowars would sometimes make 800
000 in a single day but check out this
incredible exchange
what compensation would you believe to
be appropriate
what compensation do i think appropriate
despite these numbers that were
presented the best week we ever had
that's when kobe was starting
and
there was a run on historical food
nationwide
[Music]
it doesn't really matter
about that i understand but i can answer
the question however i wish i'm not
borrowed from talking
no you are at this stage right now the
question is what compensation would be
appropriate
any compensation above
two million dollars will
no appropriate not to you
appropriate for what happened to them i
mean i mean i think it's appropriate for
whatever whatever you decide you want to
do okay because i'm really uh that's a
great answer thank you
this was just like i've never seen
anything like this and again the
question is based on the acts what do
you believe is appropriate and alex
jones is saying
we can't afford anything over two
million dollars which also by the way
seems to be a lie one of the other
things that's been going on and then
we're going to go to a break and we're
going to get back to a little bit of
this later actually one of the other
things that's been going on is that
again while the trial has been taking
place on his program alex jones has been
saying things about uh the trial the
judge and the jury
and um the judge also making an effort
there
to uh probably to prevent a mistrial or
subsequent appeal by asking direct
questions about the members of the jury
are you aware that this jury consists of
16 intelligent fair-minded citizens who
are not being improperly influenced in
any way
yes i don't think that you are
operatives i don't think that you are
part of a false flag
even alex jones no matter where he goes
in life he can't get away from this
false flag operative stuff he's now in a
defamation trial and he has to clarify
he's not saying the jurors are part of a
false flag you are bad people these are
good people and
i just am very very critical about
the whole process that i've been through
so far
where i've given i believed everything
over
and then i'm always told we didn't even
though we're seeing it and so that's why
i'm really concerned uh because a lot
has been misrepresented you've wandered
off the question
do you feel you're getting a fair trial
and if not why not
but
i'm bored from saying succinctly please
i have been found guilty by a judge
and i fought in america you're found
guilty by juries
there's no guilty or innocence in civil
court
you couldn't write something i mean this
is just unbelievable i understand liable
or not not guilty so please don't use
that you're not a lawyer that's fine
okay well
i've been found libel
okay so by a judge and and and
in all the other cases coming up have
already been found so
this is a dangerous new system they're
setting up and if people want to get rid
of that and get rid of america it's okay
i understand we're an old republic maybe
time for us to go get rid of america if
alex jones has to pay up because of the
things that he said
it's the end of america folks incredible
unprecedented and just dozens and dozens
of emails from people in the audience
pouring in about this insanity
and we'll get back to a couple other
elements of it a little bit later in the
show if you're curious about what these
clips look like and you're just
listening today you'll be able to find
these clips on our instagram david
pakman's show find us there
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
u.s is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds this has
happened to me before i've talked on the
show we got hacked it was costly it
wasn't a good feeling and that's why i
now protect myself with aura one of our
sponsors protecting your accounts and
devices gets complicated because you
need a bunch of different tools and aura
combines them all into one app identity
theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches
probably something you want to know and
it's free so you might as well just use
the link down below